two recent flights using the Boeing 737
max eight aircraft crashed due to
similar altitude fluctuations killing
everyone on board we tend to hear that
flying is extremely safe but why do some
planes crash and is there a safest seat
that you can choose or a safest time of
day to fly commercial flights are
incredibly safe in 2017 there was one
fatal accident for every 16 million
flights but small private planes crash
at rates similar to cars the majority of
the accidents are due to the pilot
losing control or controlled flight into
terrain meaning the pilot didn't see the
ground a mountain or another obstacle
until it was too late
in general amateur pilots have
significantly less training and looser
rules than commercial pilots for
commercial flights according to the
bureau of aircraft accidents archives
there were 1182 accidents between the
years 2010 to 2018 the reason for these
accidents can be broken down into four
main categories human error weather
mechanical error and sabotage human
error is the cause of the majority of
crashes using data from 1020 commercial
flight accidents these errors were
predominantly skill based errors and
decision errors skill based errors
include not conducting proper visual
scans accidentally turning on or off
switches and not complying with
checklists a pre-flight checklist is a
list of tasks to be performed by the
pilot and crew before takeoff and this
can significantly reduce risk a 2014
crash that killed seven people could
have been prevented if they had
completed the pre-flight checklist and
released a piece of equipment the gust
lock before takeoff decision errors are
conscious choices that result in poor
outcomes for example once the pilots of
that same flight realized the problem
with the gust locks they unsuccessfully
tried to disengage the equipment instead
of stopping the flight human error can
be minimized with adequate sleep for
example a study of 435 pilots found that
90% experienced fatigue and another
study found an increased probability of
accidents as the duty time increased a
separate study of American plane
accidents from 1982 to 2013 found that a
core
were related to whether the most fatal
weather conditions are precipitation low
cloud cover and fog all of which impact
visibility the most lethal months to
travel are December and January one of
the deadliest crashes occurred in 1977
when two Boeing 747s collided into one
another on the runway during a period of
thick fog 583 people died other studies
have found that these weather conditions
often involve pilots pushing the
aircraft and themselves beyond their
limit for example Scud running where a
pilot lowers altitude to avoid flying in
the clouds or get home itis where the
pilot desires to get home quickly and
overrides their sound decision-making
mechanical errors are involved in 23% of
fatal accidents the main problem being
engine failure however this is far less
likely to occur in large jet aircrafts
than in smaller propeller planes for
example an Air France Airbus crashed
killing all 228 passengers and crew due
to a frozen pitot tube pitot tubes are
sensors on the side of the plane used to
measure airspeed but when they froze
over they gave inconsistent readings not
knowing the speed of your plane can
result in deadly outcomes where you
might under speed which can lead to
stalling or over speed where the
aircraft will start to break apart as
the structure isn't meant for such high
speeds finally the most unlikely cause
of a crash is sabotage accounting for 7%
of airplane fatalities these do include
the September 11th terrorist attacks
however these types of incidents were
the highest in China is there anything
you can do to increase your chance of
survival if you were in a crash a 2007
article by Popular Mechanics analyzed
every commercial plane crash in the
United States since 1971 and found that
those in the back of the plane had a 69%
chance of survival
compared to a 49% chance when you're
sitting at the front in 2012 an uncrewed
Boeing 727 filled with crash test
dummies found similar results the front
wasn't the best place to sit this is why
we have the black box a highly protected
box resistant to fire and explosion that
records data and cockpit audio and it's
located at the back of the plane this
data has been very helpful in linking
the tragic
Ethiopian Airlines flight 302 to the
Indonesian lion Air flight 610 we're in
both cases altitudes fluctuated sharply
learning from these black boxes helps
minimize these horrifying events and
though devastating it is important to
remember that air travel remains our
safest means of transportation thank you
so much for watching you can click over
there to watch our video what would
happen if you're playing two-hour burst
opened mid-flight it's horrifying also
if you want to keep up to date on the
latest science news and scientific takes
on controversial topics make sure to
check out our podcast site now put links
over there and in the description as
well our latest episode was about
vaccines make sure you subscribe for
more science videos every Thursday and
we'll see you next work